Where I left off in the last
video we saw that if we had a
magnetic field coming in from
the right and we had this loop
of-- I guess we call it-- metal
or a circuit, and it's
carrying a current where the
current is coming in this
direction--.
You can imagine positive
protons, although we know the
electrons go in the
other direction.
But the current is coming in
this direction and going out
that direction.
We figured out using the right
hand rule and just this
formula, that the net force of
the magnetic field coming in
this direction on this arm
of the wire or the
circuit is net downwards.
And on this arm, it
was net upwards.
And so it provided a net
torque on this circuit.
Or, as I said in the last
video, a paper clip.
And where this dotted line
is the axis of rotation.
And this is how I showed
you it would rotate.
Where the magnetic field is
essentially pushing up on the
right hand side and pushing down
on the left hand side.
It has no effect over here on
the top and the bottom.
So it would rotate in
this direction.
And then this was kind of what
it looks like after it rotates
a little bit.
And the whole reason why I did
this, I said, well, this arm--
which is the same as
this arm-- the net
force is still upwards.
Out of our screen.
But that upwards direction is
now no longer going to be
completely perpendicular to
the moment arm distance.
That's the moment
arm distance.
Now the moment arm distance is
kind of coming at an angle out
of the page.
So only some of this net outward
force for the magnetic
field is going to
be perpendicular
to the moment arm.
And so the torque on it will be
less, but it's still going
to be torque in that
same direction.
Kind of coming out of the page
on the right and into the page
on the left.
And the same is true of
the left hand side.
And you go all the way to the
point that the coil is
actually vertical.
Where this side, this side
right here, is on top.
And this side is on bottom,
below the plane
of your video screen.
And at that point, the torque--
actually, there is no
net torque.
And why is that?
Because on this top part, when
it's pointing straight out at
you, when it's right here, the
magnetic field-- the force of
it, the force that's affecting
the circuit-- is pushing
straight up.
So there's no longer any net
torque because the force is
pushing straight up and that
moment arm distance-- this
distance-- is now also
pointing straight up.
And torque is also a cross
product, so you actually care
about the perpendicular
forces.
So there, at this vertical
point, there's no net torque.
And the same is true at the
bottom of the circuit.
Because at the bottom the
magnetic field force is going
to be downwards, which is
parallel with the moment arm
distance, so there's
no net torque.
And I said, well maybe there's
a little bit of angular
momentum that keeps this
object rotating.
And then it will rotate to--
and this is where it gets
interesting.
I'll draw it neatly.
Then it'll rotate
to this point.
Once again I want to have
the perspective.
It'll rotate here.
So let me just make sure
I have all of it.
So here it was rotating in this
direction and in that direction.
And then here maybe some--
there's no longer any torque
on it, but it still might on the
top be moving to the left,
and on the bottom moving
to the right.
Up to a point, then it's going
to get into this configuration
where soon. this side is-- so
at this point it has rotated
more than 90 degrees.
So this edge is now this edge.
It had rotated from here all the
way-- it's still pointing
out of the screen.
But if this edge is the same as
this edge, now the current
direction is going
to be like this.
Because this edge has
rotated down.
So it's rotated from that
position all the way back to
this position.
So the current is now coming--
let me make sure, let me draw
that right.
The current is coming like that,
like that, like that.
Going up here, to the
right, up like that.
So the current now on this left
hand side, although it
was the former right
hand side.
It's still going in that
upwards direction.
So when you take the cross
product, what is going to be
the net magnetic
field on that?
Or the force of the
magnetic field?
Well, you do the same
right hand rule.
Point your index finger up.
Put your middle finger
in the direction of
the magnetic field.
This is the palm, this is
your other two fingers.
Let me draw the fingernails,
just so they're painted
fingernails.
Not that mine are.
Then your thumb points
upwards.
So on this side of the coil we
still have an upwards force.
And if you do the cross product,
or you do the right
hand rule on the bottom side,
or the behind side, if you
could imagine it, you're
still going to have a
net downward force.
So now all of a sudden
you could imagine--
the thing had rotated.
So it had rotated in the way I
drew it here, where it pops
out on this side and it
goes in on that side.
And it had done it all the way
to the point where we had
rotated more than 90 degrees,
but now all of a sudden the
net force through the magnetic
field was going to reverse.
Because the side that has a
current going upwards is now
the left hand side.
So now the force from the
magnetic field is out on this
side and you're going
to want to rotate in
the opposite direction.
Hopefully that makes sense.
Just think about what happens.
Visualize this coil rotating.
So what is essentially going to
happen is you're going to
rotate like I did
here on the top.
Maybe once you get to this level
you're going to have a
little bit of angular momentum
that'll keep you rotating.
Or rotational inertia that'll
keep you rotating until you're
in something like this
configuration.
Maybe you go all the way back
to this configuration, where
it's essentially a complete
180 degree turn.
And then since on this side
the current's going to be
going up and on this side the
current's going down, because
you've essentially flipped
this thing over, then the
effect of the magnetic field is
going to say, well, upwards
on the left, downwards
on the right.
And so it's going to
turn the other way.
So if you think about it, it's
going to keep oscillating.
Let me draw it from-- well, I
don't want to draw it from
that angle, because I don't
want to confuse you.
So we have a problem.
If we wanted to turn this into
some type of electric motor
and keep it spinning, we would
either have to reverse the
current once you get into this
configuration, or either turn
off the magnetic field.
Or maybe you could reverse the
magnetic field to get it going
in the other direction.
And actually you have another
problem, which is a slightly
lesser problem, is if this was
a circuit and you just kept
turning over and over the
circuit, the wires would get
twisted here.
So you couldn't do
it indefinitely.
So the solution here is
something called a commutator.
you So let me draw
a commutator.
I have the same circuit which
I've now drawn messier.
But it has these two leads.
It has these leads that
essentially curve.
You could imagine them curving
out of the page.
And then we have a circuit.
You could imagine
leads here, too.
And this round thing and this
thing are touching each other
the whole time, so current
could pass through it.
Let me draw my battery.
This is positive and
this is negative.
So up here on the circuit the
current's always going to be
flowing in this direction.
It's always going to be flowing
in this direction,
it's always going to be flowing
up and like this.
Now when you're in this
configuration,
what's going to happen?
Well, the current is going
to flow down here.
That's going to be I and
that's going to be I.
And when you do your right hand
rule, we have the same
magnetic field.
I haven't changed the magnetic
field coming in from the left.
So just like we did before I
cleared the screen, you use
the right hand rule and you'll
figure out, well, the net
force from the magnetic field
is going to be upwards here
and downwards here.
And that's what's going to
create that net torque.
And you're going to
rotate this part.
So this part of this
contraption is going to rotate.
You could imagine maybe
there's like
a little pole here.
Maybe it's a nonconducting pole
so that none of the-- and
it's connected to an
axle somewhere.
So you can rotate along
that axis, right?
So the force of the
magnetic field is
going to create a torque.
We're going to rotate up on this
side, up out of the page
on that side, and into the
page on that side.
And then behind the page and
then back out of the page.
That's what the net
torque would be.
And then we would get it, and it
would keep doing that until
you get to the vertical
configuration.
So at the vertical
configuration, the circuit on
the top stays exactly
the same.
I'm trying my best to
draw this properly.
At the vertical configuration
one of two things can happen,
and probably the best thing is
that we actually lose contact
with the two leads.
So maybe the actual current
stops flowing when we're in
the vertical configuration.
I'll do it in the same color.
So when we're vertical
we just see the top.
We see this.
And then we see it pops
out a little bit.
And then we see this
arm right there.
And then we see that pole that's
maybe holding it or
that's helping it rotate.
But we're still having
some-- you know,
the current has ceased.
So there's not going to be any
torque, no force through the
magnetic field, because we've
lost touch at that point.
Because these things
kind of point out.
Hopefully you could visualize
how to build such a thing.
And we're still rotating in this
direction because of some
type of rotational inertia.
Then this is what the
interesting part is.
What happens when we rotate
more than 90 degrees?
And I just realized that I'm
pushing over 10 minutes, so
you can think about that a
little bit while I stop here
and continue this in
the next video.
See